- Hi everyone, welcome to the
daily home room livestream,
which is something that
all of us at Khan Academy
started up once we started
having mass school,
physical closures, I should say.
Many, now it seems like a lifetime ago,
it's just a way to keep in touch,
have interesting
conversations, and understand
what's happening in the world around us
in education and beyond.
Before we get into the conversation
with a very exciting guest
today, I always give the reminder
to folks that Khan Academy is
a not-for-profit organization
with the mission of providing
free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And we exist because of
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
I wanna give a special
shout out to several
corporate partners who've stepped up,
especially because of our COVID response.
You could imagine, our
traffic is almost three times
what it typically is,
our costs are going up,
we're trying to put
more programs out there
sooner than later.
And so special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, Novartis, AT&T,
Fastly for stepping up,
and for the many other supporters
for Khan Academy over the years.
We would not be able to
do what we're doing now
if not for the many years of support.
And we're still running at a deficit,
so whether you're a corporate partner,
or even a small donor who can give $3, $5,
everything makes a difference
so that we can continue
to accelerate what we're offering.
With that, I'm really eager
to introduce our guest,
Chancellor Richard
Carranza is the chancellor
of the New York City Public Schools,
the largest school district in America.
And obviously the school
district in a part of the country
that has had unusual
challenges as we've gone
through this crisis.
Chancellor Carranza,
thanks so much for joining.
- Sal, thank you so
much for the invitation.
I'm really honored to be here,
and I wanna say hi to everybody,
I'm sure many of our students
are watching as well,
because they love what you do.
So thank you for the invitation.
- No, no.
And so what I'm fascinated by is,
I would love, what was
going on in your life?
You are a New Yorker, and
obviously you're the head
of the largest school
district, highly complex
school district, in the country.
What was going on in your
head in, what was it,
the end of March when it was clear
that we had a pandemic
in the United States,
it started to become clear that New York
was getting hard hit,
and people were at least
starting to surface the
notion of school closures?
What was going on in your mind?
- Well we had been preparing
for that eventuality
back, end of February.
And one of the things that pernicious
about this pandemic and this virus
is that it's had so many iterations.
It keeps on iterating,
and it looks different.
But we were trying to be prepared.
So when the decision was made on March 16
that we would transition
to remote learning,
the one thing that we kept in mind
was that school was not closing.
We were gonna continue learning,
but it was just not gonna be
in a face-to-face environment.
And that's why we say we've
been in remote learning mode.
Ever since then, it's been just a matter
of making sure that our teachers,
and our students, and our
families, quite honestly
because caregivers, parents, guardians,
grandmothers, neighbors,
they've all kind of become
new teachers as well, and
supports for their students.
So we're making sure that
the entire organization
is really pivoted to developing resources,
providing resources,
and supporting students
and families in remote learning.
- And I wanna remind everyone,
if you have questions
for Chancellor Carranza or myself,
feel free to post your questions
on Facebook and YouTube,
where this is streaming,
and we have team members
who are gonna be able to
surface questions to us.
Chancellor Carranza, in the week or two
before March 16, when the schools closed,
what was the order of operations?
There's so many schools,
I think it's 1.2 million
students you have, how did y'all
think about internet access?
How did you think about school lunches,
special needs students?
How did you juggle all of that?
- So I have an incredible team of folks
that I work with that had already started
doing the logistical
planning around those issues,
but obviously we were
very concerned about,
if you remember during that time period,
even the medical professionals
were learning new things
about how this virus
was promulgating itself
in the community.
So we were trying to stay up-to-date,
because school was still in session.
And following the advice
of our medical experts,
we were very much into protocols
about if there's a self-reported case,
if there's a confirmed
case, what is the protocol?
Do we shut down the school?
How do we notify families?
But as we became more and more apparent
that we were gonna go
into remote learning,
then the focus was really about
our most vulnerable students,
students with disabilities,
our multi-lingual
learner students, our immigrant students,
students in temporary
housing, which is a term
that we use in New York
City for homeless students,
and all of our vulnerable populations.
At the same, we were also very concerned
about the fact that New York City,
almost nine million
residents in New York City,
and it was very clear that
the emergency responders,
our medical personnel,
our essential workers,
really depend on the
schools for their students
to be taken care of.
So at the same time as we were planning
how to transition to remote learning
and shut the physical buildings down,
we were also standing
up over 150 what we call
regional enrichment centers, REC sites,
all over the city of New
York and every borough,
specifically for the
children of first responders,
medical personnel, and essential workers,
so that they would have,
they could still continue
to serve the residents of New York City
and know that their children
would be taken care of.
That was a surreal experience,
because now you have children
in a school environment,
so all of the social distancing,
and the face masks, and the precaution,
and having 24/7 cleaning
happening all the time,
and how do you serve the food?
All of those were the things
that we were talking about
and planning for.
In addition, we know that
over 80% of the students
in New York City's public schools
qualify for free or reduced lunch.
So the poverty is real.
We know that many of our students
get their meals at school,
so at the same time we planned for,
and stood up over 450
meal hubs across the city,
in every borough, where students can come
get breakfast, lunch and
dinner all in one fell swoop.
And then about three weeks ago we extended
that to not only
children, but any resident
can come to a meal hub and
get all three meals as well.
So we stood that up as
well because we know
that it's important for
students, and their parents,
not to go hungry.
I'll tell ya this Sal, right now,
since we transitioned March 16,
we have served almost nine
and a half million meals
out of those food hubs, and
we're averaging right now
a little over half a million meals per day
that are being distributed.
And then we're also doing other things.
We heard from some of
our students that said,
"You know, during the school year,
"we get feminine hygiene products
"at our school for free, and
there's a need for that."
So we've started now distributing
feminine hygiene products
at these meal hubs.
Again, trying to be responsive
to the needs of our community
in making sure that they're
being taken care of.
- That's incredible, I can't even imagine
the complexity of doing
all of that so quickly.
And we have a lot of comments coming in.
One, just from Facebook, David Wang says,
"Thanks for taking care of the homeless
"and those who don't speak English."
TL Kwo from Facebook says
"REC sites, fantastic idea."
And they're asking what it's like,
you kind of described it already.
It seems like it's a
hard, and I hadn't even
thought about that dimension of the crisis
until you just talked about it,
that yes, these healthcare workers
need some type of support.
There's a question here
from Leslie Eldegril
from YouTube, "I work
for the valuable cause
"of education in Georgia's
Kennesaw State University,
"what can educator prep programs do
"to support what you believe will be
"the new norm Chancellor Carranza?"
And I'll add a question.
So there's the short-term,
how did you navigate that,
where you had to go
whatever you wanna call it,
remote learning, distance
learning, in fairly short order?
What were the expectations?
How did you do training?
And then, what do you think
is, to Leslie's question,
what do you think is going
to be the new normal,
if there is one?
- Great questions, so thank you
for both of those questions.
So let me give some context.
So when we decided that
we would close schools,
we were fortunate that we
had three days to prepare
for remote learning.
And people are gonna
say, "What do you mean
"you had three days?"
Well in essence, we took a
system of over 150,000 teachers,
1.1 million students, and
in a matter of three days,
72 hours, we completely
transitioned to remote learning.
Now we know that many of our teachers
were already experienced
with, and had done work with,
virtual learning, remote
learning, online learning,
blended environments, flipped classrooms,
really incredible work
here in New York City.
But we also know that there was a modicum
of our teachers that had
never had that experience.
So it was a crash course,
a bootcamp if you will,
those three days, to
make sure that teachers
had their devices, knew where to log in.
We created something in our department
learning management
system called TeachHUB,
where we've put links, a link
to Khan Academy's in there,
and lots of resources for teachers
to teach remotely from home.
So we stood that up, we
did intensive training
for those three days, and then we went
into remote learning mode, and the schools
have been closed, except for the ones
that are functioning as food hubs,
or these REC centers.
So for us, it was really making sure
that the educators had what they needed.
What was also important was to recognize
that not all of our students had devices.
So immediately, for those three days,
schools assigned the school-based laptops
and devices to their
students, again prioritizing
the most vulnerable students first,
students that needed those devices,
so students went home with those devices.
There are about 175,000 of those devices.
But what we immediately did as well
is we worked with whoever could actually
produce for us, and that
happened to be Apple.
So we put in an order for
300,000 WiFi-enabled iPads.
And I'm happy to tell
you, and we did a survey
and we had principals
and teachers in contact
with their students, they were giving us
that information as to who needed devices.
And remember, these are 1800
schools in New York City,
so lots of information flowing to us.
But I'm happy to report
that as of this week,
we've now delivered, shipped and delivered
over 290,000 devices that are in the hands
of our students right now.
So short-term versus long-term,
the short-term is making
sure that our students
had those devices,
making sure our teachers
had the support that
they needed to transition
to remote learning, but the long-term
implications are vast and profound.
And this gets to the
question that came in as well
about teaching programs.
A crisis is always an opportunity
to do something better.
And we, in education, have lamented
the digital divide for decades.
This has forced us, across the country,
to really take on the digital divide.
And if there's any silver
lining with this pandemic,
it's that when we get to the other side
of this pandemic, we will have bridged
the digital divide in New York City.
That's an amazing, amazing accomplishment.
But I think it's an
important accomplishment.
Now what that means is that
teacher preparation programs,
we're never gonna go
back to the way it was.
So technology and being
able to find resources
and utilize resources in different ways,
the ability, using
technology, to personalize,
even more so, the
learning needs of students
in a very individualized way.
We are seeing that
there's tremendous power
right now, in the hands of
teachers, to be able to do that.
So if I was a professor
in a teaching university,
preparing teachers, I would be insisting
that we have lots of pedagogy
for this flipped classroom,
online teaching, virtual teaching,
that teachers have the
wherewithal to be able to use
Google Classroom, or to
be able to use the Zoom,
or to be able to use
Microsoft Teams, or WebEx,
because it'll provide
them with additional tools
in their pedagogical toolkit to be able
to continue this trend that
students will be learning
in virtual mode, at least
some segment of their day.
And it provides us with a
lot of other opportunities.
I'll give you just one more example,
sorry for going on and
on, but I'll give you
one more example.
- No, no, no,
this is super interesting.
- So when you think about the fact
that in AP classes,
advanced placement classes,
(Richard clears throat)
in New York City,
excuse me, in New York City,
we have over 700 high schools,
we have some very small high schools
that may not have the ability
to have an AP teacher for,
let's just say AP statistics.
So what we piloted this year
was a virtual remote AP class,
a bunch of AP classes, and the notion was
that if we have a very well trained,
very capable AP teacher,
let's say in statistics,
and they're at their
school doing their job
and doing a great job, but we know there's
five other schools that have students,
one student at one school, two
students at another school,
three at another, if we can
set up that virtual classroom
with that teacher,
providing AP instruction,
and then those students
remotely, at those other schools,
are able to tap into that teacher
and get their AP
instruction, would it work?
Well it was working gangbusters
before we went into remote learning.
Guess what?
That has provided us
now with the opportunity
to think about, "Okay, how do we leverage
"the real skillset that we have embedded
"in our teachers, and provide
those learning opportunities
"to more and more students,
especially in students
"in communities that have
been historically underserved,
"and especially in small
schools where you don't
"necessarily have a lot of teachers,
"but you still have students that wanna
"have those experiences?"
Those are the kinds of experiences
that I think have
presented themselves to us
as a response to this crisis.
And I think that we have a responsibility
not to lose momentum once we get back
to in-person learning.
In-person learning will look different.
- Now I love that last example,
because it really shows how
there's maybe a silver lining
that maybe these teachers are able
to go beyond the confines of
their individual classrooms,
and it's kind of like the whole district
is serving the whole district,
which is really, really powerful.
Tons of questions and
comments from Facebook,
Shelly Fox says, "Thank
you to the New York City IT
"device deployment team."
I actually relate to that.
You just kind of nonchalantly said,
"Yeah, we deployed 290,000 laptops,
"and we've essentially
solved the digital divide."
Exactly how did that happen?
'Cause we've talked to a lot of districts,
obviously to leverage
Khan Academy you need
device access, internet access.
I am curious about the
broadband aspect of it,
and then just how did you pull that off?
There's other superintendents
who might listen
to this and they would love to be able
to emulate what you did.
- So I wanna give tremendous kudos
to our device deployment office as well,
to our purchasing and
procurement office, to our mayor.
So very early on when we
knew that this device issue
was going to be an issue,
we immediately jumped
into action mode and we contacted,
we put out calls to see who could actually
handle the volume that
we were going to need,
and Apple stepped right up and said,
"We will make sure that
we get you what you need
"in record time," and
they kept their word.
We also worked with IBM that helped us
with the installation
of the WiFi capability,
then we worked with FedEx
and UPS to develop a protocol
of how these would be shipped,
because obviously if we were then under
a stay at home order, and
we're trying to limit contact,
the last thing you wanna do
is having people come out
to have to get their devices.
So all of those partners were incredible
at making sure that they prioritized
getting these devices into
the hands of students.
And then what we also did is made sure
that we had a way of
surveying our students
and our teachers to find those individuals
that maybe hadn't raised their hand
and said, "I need a
device," so that we weren't
leaving anything to chance.
And as those devices started coming in,
again, they were prioritized for
our most vulnerable populations.
We went from there and
we expanded outward.
We still have devices so
that if, there may be a case
where a student had their own device
and now it's broken, they can request one
and we'll ship it right to them.
It was a massive undertaking, but we had
some incredible colleagues here
in the Department of Education
that just jumped right into action.
One of the things that we also did
with these devices is that
we didn't want any family
to feel that they
couldn't request a device
because "what if it breaks?
"Am I responsible for it?
"I'm not working."
So what we did is every device comes,
right out of the box
it comes WiFi enabled,
they get a hard case with it,
and we also purchased insurance
for every single device.
So our students and
parents don't have to worry
if something happens.
We wanted them to have the device as well.
And you know, in New
York, we sometimes get
a little blase about
the size of the numbers,
but you're right, 290,000 devices,
it's as if you took Seattle and you took,
I think in Seattle, Detroit,
San Francisco and Boston,
and put 'em all together,
and we just provided
all of those systems with devices,
that's kind of what
the team was able to do
in pretty record time.
- And how are you all tackling,
and that's amazing, first of all,
and how are you tackling
the broadband issue?
Have the telecom carriers
helped out there?
- Yes, so our telecom
providers have been great,
they've really stepped up
and provided WiFi access
for our students, especially our students
that live in temporary
housing, or students
that are in our public housing units.
That was the first place that they went in
and made sure that there
was WiFi available.
We are in discussion with them now,
obviously when we first went
into remote learning mode,
which was in March, the plan was
that we would come back to
face-to-face learning in April.
Well obviously that didn't happen,
we're finishing the
academic year through June
in remote learning.
Summer learning will be in
remote learning mode as well.
And as I've mentioned,
our goal is to be back
in in-person learning September,
but again, the medical
experts are gonna dictate
how fast we come into in-person learning.
So I have the entire organization focused
on remote learning through the
rest of this calendar year,
just to be prepared.
So we are in conversations now
with all the carriers about extending
that Wifi access and looking
at what that would look like.
But I have to say that,
in times of crisis,
you really see the true
nature of individuals
and organizations, and
I just cannot say enough
about what our WiFi
providers have done about,
I've mentioned some of
the shipping companies,
the technology companies,
but a lot of partners that
provide online resources
and online materials
have really stepped up
in a very unprecedented way
to support our children.
And I'd like to say to them, "Thank you,"
because without their assistance,
I know that we would not be as successful
with it as I think we are.
We've got a lot of work to do,
we're definitely building the plane
as we fly the plane, but
we couldn't have done it
without these partners and businesses,
so I just wanna give them a big public
shout out and thank you.
- No, definitely.
What you just described
over the last five,
that's one of the best
stories I've heard, frankly,
in the last couple of weeks.
And obviously I've had
a lot of conversations
with folks about the digital divide
and device access, and
that really gives me hope
for where we can go.
And to your point, not
just through this crisis,
but post-crisis, hopefully
the digital divide
will be a smaller divide, or
hopefully even get solved.
You touched on summer and back to school,
how do you think summer's going to be
different this year?
Historically things like summer programs
would be for a subset of kids,
maybe the kids who might've
fallen behind a bit.
Do you think it's going to be,
"Hey, everyone needs to just keep learning
"through the summer?"
- Well I think one thing
I don't think we speak
enough about, and it's
critically important,
is that the children, and
everyone in New York City,
but everyone in the world, and definitely
in the United States, New York city
was the epicenter of the
epicenter in the United States,
which was New York State.
So we were in the
epicenter of the epicenter,
we've been hit hard.
We've lost colleagues,
everybody knows somebody
that has been lost due
to this coronavirus-19.
So we can't forget the
trauma that our students,
and our staff, and our
community has undergone.
It's a traumatic event.
And we are starting to see
some of the signs of the trauma
with students, and students
not being able to sleep.
So I saw this also when
I was superintendent
in Houston and we were
hit by Hurricane Harvey,
and I remember seeing the
manifestation of trauma
and how that affected
people in different ways.
And the same thing is happening with this.
So as much as I want
students to continue to learn
and always to be learning, I also think
that the first opportunity that we have
for students to just breathe,
that's gonna be good.
We've embedded social-emotional learning,
trauma-informed curriculum,
trauma-informed supports
in all of the materials,
in all of the resources
that we've provided for teachers.
We also have a parent
hub, where parents have,
not all of them, but they
have a lot of resources
that they can use to
work with their students,
their children, and help
support their children
as they work through it, and they can
work through it as well.
But I think that the
trauma-informed approach
is gonna be critically important
as we come back to in-person learning.
As a result of that, I also think
that summer, we're gonna
prioritize our vulnerable students.
Obviously students with
disabilities will be prioritized
over the summer.
We've had remote learning
plans for every one
of our students with disabilities
that has adapted their
individual education plan
for a remote learning environment.
We also instituted,
through a lot of feedback,
but we instituted a new grading policy,
because you can't, a new
attendance policy as well,
you can't shove the old attendance policy
into a remote learning environment,
it just wouldn't work.
So we have a new attendance policy,
we also have a grading policy,
and in essence, students
are continuing to work,
they're continuing to turn in assignments,
but instead of failing,
no student's gonna get
a failure at the end
of this academic year,
what they'll get is an in progress grade.
And what the in progress grade signifies
is that they have a
little bit more work to do
to finish the requirements of the class,
or finish the requirements of the grade,
you know third grade or fourth grade.
And then those students
will be prioritized
for summer learning in the remote learning
environment as well.
And the whole point is to
give students more time.
And even there I would just say this,
"The goal as an educator, for me,
"has always been that students
master the subject matter,
"that they get mastery."
I'm not necessarily wanting students
to go for the A, the B, the C,
I want them to master what
they're trying to learn.
So this has forced us
now to really embrace
this notion of mastery learning.
So if the student hasn't
mastered that subject matter,
they're not gonna get a failure,
they're gonna get in
progress, and that says,
"You have some more work to do,
"we have some more work
to do to support you,"
because the goal is not
that you finish first,
but that you finish.
And that, again, is changing the narrative
for how we look at,
and how we give weight,
to what grades really are.
So anyway, that's how we're prioritizing
for summer learning.
And I'll tell ya that
many of the organizations
and institutions in New York City,
the museums, the Park and Rec Department,
the libraries, are really working with us
to be able to create, even if
it's some virtual experiences
that students can have
over the summer as well.
So it's not just reading,
writing and arithmetic,
but they also have some other
experiential experiences
that they can engage in, even if it's in
a virtual way, over the summer.
- Wow, and just so you
know, you're getting
a lot of praise on social media.
Peggy says, "Chancellor
Carranza, what a great leader.
"Really getting this from every angle,
"it's rare to find people
with these abilities."
And I think that we can
all sense the authenticity.
We have a little bit of time left.
What do you see as the
scenarios for back to school?
Obviously there's the two
extremes where we stay
fully remote, or we go
completely back to normal,
but what are the other scenarios
that you're contemplating?
And how do you think things
might be changed forever
because of this?
- Well, again, we're
always gonna be driven
by what the medical experts tell us.
So we're gonna listen to the science.
As a parent, I would not want my child
to go back to a school environment
unless I was confident that my child
was gonna be safe,
secure, and not infected.
So there's a number of things
that are beyond our control as educators,
and my control as a chancellor.
And so we're gonna listen
to the medical experts
and make sure that we have the protocols
and the materials, the
testing that we need,
and the precautionary gear
that we'll need as well.
But we've actually been
modeling a number of scenarios.
I'll just give you an example of a couple.
And these are by no
means do I mean to say,
this is exactly what's gonna happen.
It's gonna be driven by
whatever the circumstances
are at the time that the
decision has to be made
about going back to
in-person learning or not.
But I'll give you an example.
So when we come back, it's pretty obvious
that we're gonna have to probably still
practice social distancing.
How do you practice social distancing
in the very, very
tight-knit, tight quarters
that are New York City's public schools?
We're a very compact city.
So almost nine million residents,
how do you do that in our schools?
Well, so if you have an elementary school,
for example, does that mean
then that you have shifts?
So you have an early morning shift,
and part of your students
comes in the early morning,
and then you have an afternoon shift,
and the other half of the students
come to that part of the learning?
And then how do you
split teachers' schedules
to cover both shifts?
That could be one thing.
Or do you do something where it becomes
a little bit more of a remote learning?
So for example, you take
that same elementary school
and you do a cohort model.
So you take all of the students,
you have cohort one, two, and three.
Cohort one goes to school
while cohorts two and three
practice remote learning on Monday.
On Tuesday, cohort two goes to school
while cohorts one and
three are remote learning.
On Wednesday, cohort three goes to school
while one and two are
practicing remote learning.
That's only because you wanna provide
the distance to do social distancing.
What would it look like?
We know that the CDC has talked about,
as part of what their recommendations are,
is that students don't
congregate in lunch rooms
whenever they get back
to in-person learning.
That they'll eat their
lunch and their breakfast
in the classroom.
So what does that look like then?
And how do you deliver it?
How do you serve it?
How do you clean up after it?
What does the day look like?
What do buildings look like?
Are there buildings that
we are just not gonna
be able to use because
they're just physically
not equipped to handle
the social distancing
that may be required?
All of those questions, and
a myriad of other questions
are things that, right
now, we're grappling with
and modeling to see how
that would look like.
But it gives you a little insight
to the complexities that all educators,
and all of my colleagues,
and our system's leaders
are really grappling right now with.
And we're doing it in an environment
that we don't know what the ground floor
is gonna look like when we get to June,
and July, and August.
We just don't know.
I'll give you one other example of how
the ground is shifting
right beneath our feet.
Two weeks ago, nobody was talking about
PMIS, which is a pediatric
multi-system syndrome,
which I think is Kawasaki disease.
Children are getting very, very sick.
In New York City, we
have over 100 students
that are being treated for that syndrome.
And we know that doctors are exploring,
is there a relationship
between COVID-19 exposure
and then this syndrome?
Two weeks ago we weren't
even talking about that.
So that's how rapidly this
is manifesting and iterating.
This virus is iterating,
so the sand is definitely
shifting beneath our feet.
So what we're trying
to do is model a number
of scenarios and be prepared so whatever
those circumstances are,
we can pivot very quickly
to a model, or at least we've thought
about what some of these
implications would be
as we make those decisions to go back
to in-person learning.
- Wow.
Well Chancellor Carranza,
given all that you've done,
one it's heartening, and as I said,
there's a lot of good news embedded in,
obviously, the larger not so good context
that we are all dealing with,
especially that y'all are
dealing with in New York.
But I think I speak for everyone watching
that you'll keep doing the amazing work
that you and your team are doing.
It gives confidence in
folks to see leadership
like what you're providing,
and I'm honored, frankly,
that you're able to make a little bit
of time for us today,
because I can imagine
there's many, many things
going on in your world.
So thank you so much for joining us
and I hope we can do this
again in a few weeks.
- I would love to do it, and thank you
for the invitation.
And to everybody that's out
there watching, listening,
stay safe, take care of each other.
This is a time for us to
take care of each other.
So thank you for the
opportunity, and be safe.
- Thank you.
Well thanks everyone for joining,
I hope you were as inspired as I was.
I think in times of
stress and times of crisis
that people show their true colors,
and I think you're seeing examples
of really great leadership
from Chancellor Carranza,
and from many others that we've had.
And it's heartening to see how folks
have been stepping up
to do the right thing.
Look forward to joining
you on future livestreams.
I will see all of y'all tomorrow.
Stay safe and stay healthy, just like
Chancellor Carranza told us.